he comes back to himself into the world
of Multiplicity but now he sees it in a
completely different way
he no longer views his self as an
independent entity but only as the
self-disclosure of God his self is no
longer limited and finite but the self
with a capital s that reality which
encompasses everything in Oneness
in the end it was within himself that
the Beloved or God was to be found all
along and he now experiences that
presence of God at all levels of reality
quotes
I sought her for myself she was there
all along
how strange that I had concealed her
from me
calling to myself from me to guide me by
my voice to that part of me lost in my
search there is only God and both within
himself and in the world outside he sees
nothing but God as the Quran says quote
whichever way you turn where is the face
of God